and as I say some cheering not too much
of it from the party activists and I
want to talk now too
they was just Philips Labour candidate
one of the Labour candidates in
Birmingham and and Jess Phillips
let's stay because we're looking at
pictures of your leader would you be
cheering him would you be clapping him
if you were there this evening I might
act with courtesy so yes maybe I don't
think that it's nothing to gloat about
is there that I don't think that I don't
think that there's much the Labour Party
to feel particularly good about and to
be chopping and clapping and cheering
but you know what these things are like
it's for the cameras isn't it
well out of courtesy I mean do you think
that okay after a period of reflection
and examination you need a new leader
it would be impossible to say honest
anything other than that but you as I've
said on everybody use put a camera in
front of my face I'm not going to stand
here and scalp Jeremy Corbyn the country
once all the results are in it appears
it is making quite a clear statement
about how it feels about the Labour
Party the Labour Party's offer the
Labour Party for quite some time and you
know I'm not I'm not going to be the
person who writes your headlines because
actually I think that there are other
people I'm just a mere backbencher there
are other people who probably aren't
letting you put cameras in front of
their faces who probably should be
talking about what they think has gone
wrong and I'm not going to write your
headlines for you tonight okay we don't
you've got a change you're right we
don't know what the headlines are fully
going to be yet but so the results are
coming in in line with what the exit
poll is telling us and many people like
you prominent figures in the Labour
Party are saying yeah well it's not
going to be a good evening to to say the
least so just let me ask you but there
we are
a bit of a headline in itself
I'd say Jess Phillips but this issue of
where labor can win its it's the city's
now you're looking like you could become
almost an extinct species in in the
towns and major parts of the kind of
post-industrial northeast northwest
Wales the list goes on it won't become
extinct if we properly go out and listen
to what is going wrong and properly act
on it and actually try and do something
it's funny because Jeremy Corbyn is
always being seen as being of radical
something radically different but the
reality is is the Labour Party needs to
radically change because I don't believe
it's extinct in towns or in places where
I am absolutely certain as somebody who
represents a leave seat that has
suffered terribly from austerity that
the Conservative Party will be found
incredibly one thing and so I don't
think that the Labour Party is extinct
and I think it has every chance to
rebuild itself but that notwithstanding
tonight is terrible it's horrendous it's
heartbreaking it's painful it's painful
for the people that I need to serve it's
painful for all of my constituents who
are facing real challenges because of
decisions made by the people who have
governed us for nearly a decade
I remember when things used to get
better and now people have just got used
to things getting worse okay and that is
a tragedy that tonight the Labour Party
wasn't able to rescue them from that
okay Joe